like the fourth oldest
GE bro that is actually delicious woman
how do I do
[Music]
it kick in face
oh that was
pissing that had some talk behind
it has this tree my mate's dad planted
40 years
ago that big created his own little
ecosystem
had a pretty chill morning didn't worry
about breakfast or anything we're going
to a lookout 15 minutes away that looks
over the wetlands of the maray river and
if the wind's not too bad which I got a
feeling it's going to be pretty bad we
might get the Drone up
[Music]
[ __ ] that is some talk behind it
all right today has been pretty full on
we've recorded as much as we can we'
just been on a dairy farm one of my
mates owns a dairy farm so he's pretty
much taken us on a full tour then we
just went on the we done the whole
process of bringing the cows in which I
got Wicked Drone footage so Chuck that
in right now
[Music]
he
back
[Music]
this is a hydraulic lever which lets the
cows out fills up that with drain and
then it drops back down ready for the
the next lot to come through this the
freaky part have a look at this they
just know exactly what to
do
boom like the fourth oldest
GE bro that is actually delicious
war that is not a broken hose that is
peace straight out of the
[Music]
auto can't get much rarer milk than that
safe to say we run over a [ __ ]
landmine
watch
out way too hot fresh out of Dylan's CHS
bums can you get better than this
second Camp up that me mate dairy farm
got our own patch a
lawn cows are on their way in now some
fresh eggs beef and lamb
patties watching the cows walk into the
dairy shout out to Dylan for the fresh
eggs straight out of the uh what do you
call them kennel
[Music]
full Farm Camp [ __ ] cook
up they're old cows aren't they Jesse
yes sir straight
off straight out of the paddock straight
on the
grill hey
buser yeah good boy